sonny gray back on the bump in hot
pursuit of his first win of the 2021
season
that is lash to first nice spinning pick
a tumbling blandino who feeds gray in
stride went away
that is tap toward first blandino calmly
raises the hand says i got it
tested twice
two down
shift off
two two swinging the miss he struck him
out couple of ground the balls and a
swing and a miss by their best power bat
sonny gray a sizzling start the lefty
brett anderson and he's kind of a bounce
back after a rough start against the
atlanta braves
jesse winker going after the first pitch
and sends one over to luis urias one
pitch one out
and he goes after the first pitch and
that's a taylor made double play four
six three urias adamus and over the
volvo back in a nice efficient first
inning
fling in the middle it looks like
they pulled the string there and drew
bogo back a big ol hook
right over it back-to-back strikeouts
going back to the first inning for sonny
gray still has that same smile
and gray has it working heavy diet of
off speed he has struck out three in a
row
payoff swing into this he struck him out
four straight strikeouts nobody has
reached against sonny gray
again the 3-2
and hit sharply over to travis shaw
for route number one
anderson ready with a 1-2
got him breaking ball takes care of
blandino first strikeout for anderson
and one two three go the reds
swing and a miss strike three five
straight strikeouts for sonny gray gray
will face luisa rios
ray delivers the payoff and there's a
long fly ball into left field and it is
gone
luis urrias with number five on the year
and the brewers open up the scoring this
afternoon nice short stroke by luis on
the 3-2 pitch got a fastball paul just
jumped on out of here
and is winning winning baseball's old
school new school whatever school that
hit gray he feeds the second farmer to
first a little tall blandino stays on
the bag a much needed double play
scott heidemann now with the reds feasts
on left-handed pitching about to make
his first at-bat today
and that is rock to deep left center
field scott heinemann
[Applause]
on a 2-2 pitch and he hit it a ton into
the reds bullpen
his first home run in a red's uniform a
winker went deep three times yesterday
and there's a high fly shot to right
jesse winker he did it
almost halfway up
the sun deck
four home runs in two games gives the
reds a 2-1 lead the last time i read
homered the day after he went deep three
times greg vaughn in 1999.
as we see the padres next week at
american family field
as vogelback goes opposite field at a
base hit that's a beauty right there you
see that swing nice and easy just not
trying to do a whole lot really adonis
and there's a base head into left field
daniel vogel back will move up to second
and there's the first hit as a brewer
for willie adams yeah that was pretty
quick bat on a fastball
1-1
lifted
left field winker a longer run slows and
makes the catch
it used to be said you couldn't add
velocity we've learned since you can do
that what else are we gonna learn
there he goes into the right center gap
and that one's off the wall stevenson
turns matt he can move he's a big dude
and he can run that's an athlete legging
out the double
[Applause]
payoff pitch
that strike three call perfect busting
right in there on the inside corner true
balls two strikes to blandino here it
comes
got him struck him out for the second
time that's good work from anderson
gives up a lead off double strikeout
ground ball strikeout we're through four
strike three six strikeouts for sonny
gray
pops that one up
landino
right in front of the rolled up tarp i
think it was the aerodynamics of the top
button being undone
one two three
down the right field line that's going
to be extra bases for the brewers
catcher
on his way to second
and a leadoff double here in the sixth
for omar narvaez
gray delivers and there's a walk runners
at first and second with nobody out
one two
swing and a miss up and in with the heat
seven strikeouts for sonny gray and not
only is it in but you mentioned up and
then elevated
and a four pitch walk and they are
loaded with two men out in the sixth
with a double and two walks they are
loaded for jackie bradley jr
goes after the first pitch it goes off
the glove of blandina and the game is
tied here comes garcia play at the plate
and he's safe at home
garcia wheeling around third takes it
into the brewers
grab a three to two lead two in two on
two out bradley goes swinging to miss
high fast ball strike three eight
strikeouts for gray suiter a tommy john
guy takes on nick castianos
and he thumps that one fair down the
left field line
castiano's turns
he rips up to second base a standing
double for castillos
here is tyler stevenson he doubled his
last time up 2-1
buck up the middle that is past the dive
of robertson castellanos rounds third
kane has to eat it castillano scores
tied at three daniel robertson his first
at-bat of the day and going after the
first pitch lifting one into center
field heinemann at the wall reaching up
can't get it it's gone
daniel robertson goes deep to center
field as the brewers grab the lead again
hembree is now giving up home runs in
each of his last three appearances
drops that one down off speed swinging
of his strike three this fastball and
this breaking ball looked the same well
there's the heat from doolittle as he
lifts it up bradley swings right through
devin williams on the mound now ninth
pitch coming up williams versus winker
struck him out went to the fastball for
out number one
well one two change up got him that
winker on a fastball castillanos on the
airbender two up two down here comes the
two-strike pitch
side retired change up takes care of
business as devon williams strikes out
the side
here it comes
game over
struck him out 97 at the top of the zone
as the brewers get their first win on
this road trip excellent work out of the
bullpen
and a timely home run to say the least
from daniel robertson